hi guys in this video we want to talk
about belly swelling you know the person
that wakes out in the morning and their
stomach is somewhat flat but towards the
end of the day you feel like you're
pregnant your stomach is bulging out
what is that and how do we correct it
it's one of two things it's either high
insulin or it's low cortisol okay but
odds are high insulin it's very rare to
have it to be low cortisol but that
could be a factor so let's first talk
about the most common reason it's high
insulin so many people are insulin
resistance which basically they have
high levels of insulin there are
pre-diabetic now one thing you need to
know about insulin it is this it is a
inflammatory hormone it will create
inflammation okay so if you have too
much insulin you're going to basically
create inflammation in your gut around
the fat and it's going to swell up
that's what's happening let's talk about
what would increase insulin well you
maybe already know this but eating carbs
will do it combining protein and
carbohydrates together will do it but
there's something that's even bigger and
that would be eating in general every
time you eat you increase insulin so I'm
not saying don't eat but I'm just saying
the frequency of eating if you do five
small meals a day if you do three meals
a day and you snack at night boom you're
going to swell your belly okay so really
it's it's the spike of insulin because
you're eating so one of the best things
to do to fix this is to have do
intermittent fasting no more snacks
start with three meals a day okay no
snacks so you might have to add a little
bit of fat at the end of that meal to go
from one meal to the next and I'm sure
that you if you've been watching the
videos you already know that but for
those of you that don't I'll put a link
down below about intermittent fasting if
you can get to two meals a day you will
not have a swollen belly okay unless you
can't tolerate fat in which case you
have to reduce your fats which is
another another video but the point is
that we want to decrease carbs do
intermittent fasting for the
swelling the next thing is the cortisol
when you run out of cortisol you get
inflamed because cortisol which is an
adrenal hormone that is an
anti-inflammatory that's why if you have
pain or inflammation the doctors give
you prednisone or cortisone why because
that's an anti-inflammatory so when your
body runs out of cortisol you start
becoming inflamed it's definitely on the
gut as well and in joints as well so to
fix that you want to support the adrenal
gland itself lower the stress go for
long walks vitamin D high amounts of
potassium I'll put the link down below
to get more data on that if you need to
go into this but mainly it's going to be
this one right here all right go ahead
and apply this and tell me what you
think hi guys hey listen I created a
pretty amazing evaluation quiz down
below that actually analyzes your
symptoms to find the cause the root
cause of all of your symptoms the most
likely cause so take the quiz now and
we'll send you a report